i love the holidays so much and even
though things may
look different this year you can still
celebrate in a fun
socially distant way and our show
couldn't do a holiday party
but i still wanted to find a way to
celebrate so i got
a few of our incredible team that we
make the show with
together to decorate gingerbread houses
and helping us out with all of our
gingerbread dreams
this season is our partner walmart plus
which is walmart's new membership with
so many benefits like free shipping
and no order minimums on itemship by
walmart.com
and we used it to send our team
gingerbread houses and all the fixings
so that we could decorate it together hi
hi everybody for all the people who may
or may not be traveling
this christmas this is such a good thing
to do
over zoom for the holidays because
it's really nice to have activities
whether you're in the house with your
family
stuck all christmas or you're trying to
connect with family on zoom because
you're not traveling
i was so inspired by it because my
partner lives on the west coast and i'm
on the east coast for the holidays so i
sent him gingerbread kit so we can do it
together
that's actually a really great idea
brandon shout out to
every delivery person who is doing this
through the holidays and making all of
this possible
how far is anyone on their gingerbread
houses because i feel like
mine still feels really premature and
new me too i'm kind of winging it and
i have no idea how it's going to turn
out but i think it'll be fun regardless
yeah i thought you said you were winning
it and i was like ooh i love that
confidence
you know what i will say i'm winning it
yeah go for it
don't even question it i have a whole
bit of debate for you guys
do you prefer a real tree or a fake tree
any tree as long as they're a tree i
like a white
tree a green tree a fake tree
uh oh oh my ice thing came out the top
again
i'm squeezing all wrong i'm a bad
squeezer
my mom informed me yesterday that our
christmas tree
is real but it's sitting in a bucket in
the garage
probably until i get home are you going
home for the holidays marina
i am where are you going ann arbor i
love ann arbor really for six months
while we were making this film uh i
directed called whip
it we lived there that was actually one
of my favorite places
really yeah i dressed as a whippet
character for halloween in high school
oh my gosh marina i can't believe
that we've never talked about this
that's so mean people
what is everybody grateful for
in 2020 and what do they look forward to
in 2021 to be able to be a part of this
show and us using this platform to help
those people
who are out there who are struggling who
lost
jobs who had health issues
that's top tier right there i moved to
new york and that was something that was
like something i had really wanted to do
for such a long time
and i'm really just so thankful that i
got to be
on this show that allowed me to be here
i am excited about buying more
turtlenecks
tis the season i think all of us are
just so grateful
to have our health and be happy
and have each other my mom works in a
nursing home
so i don't know if i'm going to get to
see her this christmas uh so i'd like to
wish my mother
and my sister a very very very merry
christmas
a big merry christmas to trevor's mom
and sister
i want to show you this street really
quick this is a shout out to all of our
vff's out
trevor i love there so much i learned
so many things about life and people and
the world
and myself i think i'm gonna always hold
this year as one of the best of my life
even though it was so difficult
so in 2021 when we're all in that office
i'll know that my wish for the year has
come true
oh i can't wait for that one giant group
hug
all over each other this is my final
product what do you think
wow i
am gonna say i really
really feel good about it this was
just zen and fun and it gave me so much
joy
and i'm really happy with the outcome i
think it looks great and i think that
that's part of the whole fun of this is
it's the process getting there
and not necessarily the end result thank
you guys and i just wanted to thank
walmart plus for providing a
total life hack to help all of us save
time and money
to do more of what we love thank you
walmart
[Music]
you